[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه
معجزه فيها انقاذ وانتشال ناجعيين من اسره
تضم سبعه اشخاص واردوغان يقول ان زلزلين
كان بقوه القنابل الذريه
بعد اقرارها بالتقصير الامم تطلب 400
مليون دولار لسوريا وتدفع باول قافله
اغاثه عبر معبر باب السلامه
[موسيقى]
تقارير تصدم الناتو مخازنكم ستفرغ في ايام
ان خضتم حربا فرنسا تسعى لحل سريع مفهوم
جديد لفرق المشاده
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
واشنطن تعدل راداراتها لاصطياد الاجسام
الطائره وتبحث عن حل للغز في بقايا
المنطاد الصيني
[موسيقى]
في تداعيات زلزال تركيا وسوريا انتقلت
تحدي من محاوله انقاذ العالقين تحت
الانقاض الى محاوله ايواء واغاثه من شردهم
هذا الزلزال ووسط هذا الجهد ياتي الخبر في
تركيا من محافظه وراء اخرى عن معجزه من
اجل جديد صمد امام غياب ادوات الحياه
وقسوه البرد القارس بل وحتى اسره كامله من
سبعه اشخاص في هاتاي تم انقاذ اثنين منهم
لكن الاخبار ذاتها لا تاتي من سوريا
فالايادي والمحاول لن تكون ابدا في سرعه
فرق تركيه ودوليه تمتلك احدث التجهيز
[موسيقى]
عده اشخاص خرجوا احياء من تحت الانقاض في
تركيا
قهرمان مرعش بؤره زلزال واكثر المدن
المدمره سجلت ابرز هذه الحالات
[موسيقى]
الطفله السوريه لينا وامها كانتان ناجيتين
الابرز خلال الاربع والعشرين ساعه الماضيه
محمد انيس هو الاخر كتبت له الحياه بعد
198 ساعه عاشها تحت الركام
كذلك هذا الشاب الذي يبلغ 18 عاما وصلت
اليه فرق الانقاذ وهو بصحه جيده
وبعد 203 ساعات استطاع المنقذون انتشال
هذه السيده على قيد الحياه بمدينه هاتاي
[موسيقى]
قلع الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان قوه
الزلزلين الذين شهدتهما تركيا تعادل
القنابل الذريه معلنا ارتفاع حصيله
الضحايا الى اكثر من 35000 قتيل
جميع علماء الزلازل اتفقوا على ان الزلزال
الاخير كان من اقوى الزلازل التي حدثت في
العالم وقدروا قوته بقوه مئات القنابل
الذريه نحو 13 الف جريح يتماثلون للشفاء
في المستشفيات يعتبر حجم وشده الزلازل
ومدى تدميرها ظاهره طبيعيه استثنائيه
اتمنى الرحمه لكل القتلى الذين يبلغ عددهم
35,418 من مواطني بلدي واتمنى شفاء
المصابين الذين تم انقاذهم الذين يبلغ
عددهم وخمسه الاف وخمسمائه وخمسه جرحى
هذا وتتوالى شهادات المسؤولين الامميين عن
كارثه تركيا وسوريا فالمدير الاقليمي
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
وصف الدمار الذي وقع في تركيا باسوء كارثه
طبيعيه تشهدها المنطقه الاوروبيه منذ قرن
نشهد اسوا كارثه طبيعيه في النطاق
الاوروبي لمنظمه الصحه العالميه منذ قرن
وما زلنا نعترف على حجمها وتكلفه خسائرها
الحقيقيه وسيستغرق التعافي وقتا وجهدا
هائلا لكن يمكنني ان اؤكد لكم ان منظمه
الصحه العالميه ستبقى صامده الى جانب شعب
تركيا وسوريا طالما تطلب الامر ذلك
اما الامم المتحده التي اعترفت بالتقصير
في سوريا فقد اطلق امينها العام انطونيو
غوتير شني داء لجمع نحو 400 مليون دولار
لمساعده الضحايا مشيرا الى ان المنظمه
تعمل ايضا على اطلاق نداء مماثل لمساعده
تركيا
الامم المتحده تطلق نداء لجمع 300
مليون دولار لمساعده ضحايا الزلزال في
سوريا هذا المبلغ سيغطي فتره ثلاثه اشهر
نحن في المراحل الاخيره من اطلاق نداء
مماثل لمساعده تركيا الامم المتحده قدمت
50 مليون دولار من المساعدات فورا بعد
وقوع الزلزال من صندوق المسؤوليات العاجله
يحتاج اكثر من ذلك
اليوم دخلت اول قافله مساعدات امميه عبر
معبر باب السلامه الحدودي بين تركيا
ومناطق سيطره الفصائل المعارضه في شمال
سوريا تتالف القافله من 11 شاحنه مقدمه من
المنظمه الدوليه للهجره التي افادت بان
المساعدات تشمل مستلزمات ايواء وبطانيات
وينضم الينا من اديمان محمود شكر
العربيه اهلا بك محمود
هل تسمعني
اود ان اسالك عن المكان الذي تتواجد فيه
ونحن نرى من وراءك خيم نصبت لواء ربما
الاشخاص الذين يعني كان لديهم الحظ بانه
عاشوا من وراء هذا الزلزال المدمر
نعم اذا امكن ان ناخذ بهذه الصور الى
المكان الاخر من هنالك على بعد سبعه امتار
انتقلوا من هذا البناء
انتقلوا الى هنا الى هذا المخيم يعني كم
هي المسافه التي تفرق بينهما عشره 15 متر
ولكنها غيرت حياتهم اطلاقا هذا هو المخيم
الان هذه الصوره مصغره عن كل المخيمات
التي نصبت في المدينه مئات من الخيام التي
نصبت في الايام الماضيه والتي بدا العمل
بها ضمن خطه منظمه تقوم بها الحكومه
بالاضافه ايضا الى الجمعيات
الان كما نشاهد قامت البلديه هنا بتنظيم
وما امكن من
المواطنين الاتراك بالاضافه الى مجموعه
ايضا من النازحين السوريين في هذا المخيم
وهي تقدم لهم ما تمكنت منه من مواد اغاثيه
من طعام وشراب وغير ذلك وحتى كما نلاحظ ان
هنالك مولدات كهربائيه لاضاءه المخيم
اليوم
بدات الفرق التي كانت في المدينه تغادر
قامت الحكومه منذ حوالي ثلاث ساعات تقريبا
بعمليه ارجاع او سحب لكل العمال الذين
كانوا يعملون في المناجم والذين اتت بهم
الى هذه المنطقه كما انه علمنا ايضا الى
ان مجموعات عربيه واجنبيه المتخصصه برفع
العقاد والبحث عن الناجين ايضا بدات
بالانسحاب فغادرت الفرقه الجزائريه كما
جزء من البريطانيه وايضا التونسيه بطريقه
الى المغادره يظهر الى ان المدينه بدات
تاخذ انفاسها بان تتعود على نمط جديد من
الحياه كما نشاهده الان في هذه الصور في
مخيمات وفي مراكز الايواء وايضا في
التي خرج
الاكبر من اهالي هذه المدينه الى المدن
الاخرى
نعم
وينضم الي ايضا عبد المحسن
الحربي من غازي عنتاب اهلا بك عبد المحسن
يعني ماذا عن جهود
الانقاذ والايواء الجاريه الان حيث تتواجد
انت بغازي عنتاب
نعم بالفعل جهود الايواء
والانقاذ بشكل متزامل لا تزال تعمل مع
انخفاض وتيره عمليات الانقاذ في بعض
المناطق هنا في غازي عنتاب لاسيما في
منطقه الابراهيملي وايضا لا تزال العمليات
في الاصلاحيه وهي اصلاحيه وهي المنطقه
الاكثر تضررا هنا في غازي عنتاب بالاضافه
الى كثير من الاشخاص الذين لا زالوا في
المخيمات وفي المواقع المختلفه
يبيتون الليالي في هذه الليالي البارده في
خيم تم توفيرها لهم بالاضافه الى بعض
الاشخاص الذين لا زالوا في السيارات لا
يبرحونها مساء بعد هذه الازمات النفسيه
التي سببتها لهم هذه الضربه وهم خائفون من
العوده الى الفنادق الى البيوت الى
المناطق
المختلفه بالاضافه الى ذلك كنا في جوله
اليوم
من غازي عنتاب الى
مقر ومركز الزلزال في تلك المدينه التي
ضربها الزلزال بشكل مباشر شاهدنا عدد كبير
خلال الطريق عدد كبير جدا من
السيارات وايضا من الاشخاص المتواجدين في
مناطق الايواء على يمنه ويسار الطريق في
ذلك الموقع بالاضافه الى انقلاب ملعب
كهرمان مرعش وهو الملعب الرئيسي لتلك
المدينه الى مقر للايوان تتواجد فيه عشرات
الخيام بل وصلت الى
انها لم تعد تستقبل الكثير من الاشخاص
هنالك قائمه انتظار طويله جدا من الاشخاص
الذين يرغبون بالمكوث في ذلك المكان
للحصول على المساعدات الغذائيه والايوائيه
والطبيه
ذلك المكان بالاضافه الى الدمار المنتشر
في تلك المدينه غازي عنتاب بدات بالعوده
الى الحياه بشكل شبه طبيعي المحلات بدات
تفتح
والحركه بدات تعود
قليلا قليلا بشكل تدريجي يعني الى اي حتى
توقفت اعمال الانقاذ لانه هل الرئيس
التركي قال سنستمر
لاخر رمق يعني متى هل من معلومات متى
ستتوقف هذه العمليات واعطاء الاهميه
للايواء والاهتمام بالباقين
عمليات الانقاذ لم تتوقف فعليا هي الذي
حصل انه في بعض المناطق هنا تحديدا في
البراهيم لتم الانتهاء من العمليات
وتحديد يوم الامس بقيت فرقه تركيه مكونه
من عدد من فرق الانقاذ التركيه في مناطق
مختلفه في الابراهيملي لتاكيد وجود اربعه
اشخاص
وهم لم يعودوا على قيد الحياه فبالتالي
بقيت تلك الفرق فقط لانتشال هذه الجثث
الفرق الاخرى انتجهت الى انطاكيا التي هي
اكثر حاجه في هذا الوقت الحالي لهذه الفرق
الكبيره من عمليات الانقاذ فيما عدا ذلك
كل الفرق لا زالت تعمل اليوم في
مدن مختلفه لا تزال العمليات الانقاذ
ولكنها المواقع التي كانت تعمل في انتقلت
من موقع الى اخر هي تكتيكات لم تتوقف
وبحسب التصريحات هي لن تتوقف حتى الايام
القادمه الى ان يتم انتشار اخر جثه او
انتشال ايه ناجي متبقي في تلك المواقع
انتقل الى مفرد العربيه ايضا من اديمان
محمود شكر محمود يعني ما الذي ينقص هؤلاء
الاشخاص المتواجدين
بالمخيم حيث تتواجد انت يعني هل امنت لهم
كل
الاحتياجات تحدثت انت بانه هنالك مولدات
للكهرباء ما الذي ينقصهم
نعم على متى الايام الماضيه كان ملاحظا
وكان
بغايه الاهميه عندما نجد الى ان كل المواد
الاغاثيه من طعام و ملبس وماكل ومشربين
بالاضافه ايضا الى كل الاحتياجات الطبيه
كانت متوفره في هذه المدينه هنالك كميات
كبيره لا يمكن ان تحسب بالمئات بالالاف من
الاطان من ادق تفصيل الى اكبره الى اصغره
حتى ان الخبز الساخن امنا وفي بعض الاحيان
هناك مطاعم تؤمن الشاورما اللحمه
الذين يجلسون في هذه الخيم كانت المشكله
الاساسيه هو تامين المبيت الاساسي بعدد
كبير من
الاتراك لان المدينه باكملها هنا عصف بها
الزلزال وايضا القسم الاكبر تم نقله الى
مناطق اخرى والقسم الذي تبقى او لم تتمكن
الحكومه من نقله او لربما ايضا تضعه على
جدول
مبرمج لعمليه النقل من المدينه الى اماكن
اخرى فايضا بدات الامور على هذا المنوال
التي نراه نحن كنا منذ حوالي تقريبا نصف
ساعه في المقلب الاخر لهذا المخيم انت
الان تشاهدين المخيم من النايلون في
المقلب الاخر الذي يبعد حوالي اثنين كيلو
متر الجيش التركي يقوم ببناء مخيم كبير
جدا من الكونتينر نحن كان في جهد حتى
يسمحوا لنا بالتصوير ولكن كان اتى الامر
بالمنع هنالك قريه باكملها من الكونتيرا
انت الكونتينر هو حاله متقدمه جدا مؤهل
كافه الخدمات يعملون على امتداد المد
الكهربائي الماء ايضا اليه بالاضافه ايضا
الى هواتف الى الى شاحنات هي مجهزه لله
الثابته التي تريدين ان تقومين باي اتصال
بها بالاضافه ايضا الى ان المشكله الان
كما تشاهدين امبارح بالامس كانت سبعه تحت
الصفر اليوم نتحدث عن ثلاثه الى اربعه صفر
لن اكن مباركا اذا قلت انا كان هناك
اربعين الى خمسين شاحنه تدخل الى هذه
المدينه وهي مليئه بالاف الاطنان من الخشب
الذي يوزع على قارعه الطريق وفي اماكن من
يريد ان ياخذ لذلك اذا امكننا في السقف
العالي من هذا لنرى الدخان كيف تشاهدين
الان الدخان هو يخرج من كل هذه المخيمات
وايضا لان الطقس صعب جدا وكل خيمه هي
مجهزه بمطفئه وهذه المدفئه كما نشاهدها
الان يعني بطريقه
تقنيه ثالثه تطفئ من في الداخل وايضا تكون
طريقه جيده وسهله للاستعمال ولكن ولكن
بحسب ما علمنا ان هذه المخيمات هي مخيمات
مؤقته بانتظار اما الى الشقق واما الى مدن
اخرى واما الى مخيمات الكونتينر واما الى
مراكز الايواء كالمدارس المؤلفه من طابقين
او الجامعات المؤلفه من طابقين او القنا
منذ حوالي الساعه ايضا في مركز تنشيطي
للشباب والرياضه هو على قاعده انه كان
مركزا للترفيه تحول ايضا الى الى
تحول خليني اذهب الى هذا الصبي شو اسمك
عمو انت
انت سوري او تركي سوري انت منين من ادلب
من ادلب مسقعه وشو بردان
وين كنت
انت بدك تضلك بتركيا او بدك تروح على
هولندا
على هولندا طيب هلا عم تاكل
في اكل بالمخيم جوا حدا عم يجي يلعبكم
انا اكبر
يلا يلا روح البس
نعم يعني محمود ان كان هناك المزيد من
الاشخاص الذين يودون الحديث الى الكاميرا
معك لدينا متسع من الوقت
لا اعلم نعم لا اعلم مجموعه حضرتك اذا
سمحت حضرتك سوري او تركي سوري وين خال
الان اين تبيت
بالمخيم وين كنت قبل المخيم قبل المخيم
البيت وتدمر بتدمر البيت لا سمح الله ما
حدا من اقاربك او عائلتك لبيت الدمر ولكن
الحمد لله انا الان هل الامكانيه بقلب
الخيم مسهله
امسحها لينه تلقائيا شوي شوي الحمد لله
كله عم يصير الحمد لله كويس دافئ الحمد
لله
اكل الشربيني الحمد لله ما ناقصنا شيء
بهذا المكان
هلق تلقائيا هون لبين ما يجي
القرفنه
نعم لا ياتي الكونتينر
بالمخيمات الاغراء وعدوكم تنتقلوا الى
الكنتينير
مؤقتا هلق هون مؤقتا كهرباء موجوده مياه
موجوده في الداخل يعني الحمد لله شوي شوي
عائلتك من وين كنت بالزلزال والله بالبيت
عم يهز فجاه كيف طلعت معرفتي ان شاء الله
ما في شيء اصابات ما في مشكله كلهم بخير
الحمد لله كله بخير هو وقفنا بالشارع
الطابق تحت مني طبق على عيله سوريه الحمزه
ضلت فتحه منها فتحه صغيره
يعني انا كنت بنيتي ثلاث طوابق انا صرت
كنت الطابق تاني صرت الاول الطابق الاول
معها خالص
بالمخيم
صرنا هلا ثمانيه ايام تسعه ايام من يوم
الزلزال دغري شيتو
ما بده بالعراق بهدله كذا مسار
المستلزمات والطعام عم يجي على طعام موجود
كتير الحمد لله
بالنسبه كمان للطبابه حدا من الاولاد كذا
من نجا انه حدا مرض سخن
ميدانيه
هلا بتزعل انه انت هون كل شي عم يتاملنا
بس بالداخل السوري عم تسمع انت بالاعلام
انه الوضع صعب شو بنزعل عليهم يعني انهم
كمان الوضع نفسهم مثلا
بس
ما دخلتهم مساعدات خالص خالص
عائلتك اهلك قريبينك في الدخل أنا بالشام
الحمد لله ما في
غوطه الشام لا بالشام انا بالشام من دمشق
وقد ايه الك باثرى
ما تشعر بالحزن انك هربت من موت الى موت
كمان انه هربت من الموت قتل الموت الى هنا
ايضا هربت من الموت سبحان الله لكن الموت
سبحان الله يعني شويه
غير غيره نشوف الزلزال سبحان الله
حسب حكمته
خليني اطمئن انه الامور جيده كله سوا
الحمد لله على ما يرام ومنقول ان شاء الله
سنذهب الى الايام القادمه شكرا جزيلا لك
عزيزتي نعم نعم يعطيك الف عافيه يعني
استمعنا الى حديث
يعطيك الف عافيه شكرا جزيلا لك محمود شكر
مفوض العربي وايضا عبد المحسن الحربي من
غازي عنتاب
[موسيقى]
شاطر
وقع الزلزال وكان وقعه كبيرا على سوريا
وتركيا مع اعداد الضحايا الكبيره في
الدولتين تركيا شكلت لجنه للتحقيق في
جرائم الزلزال من وفيات واصابات والمتهمون
مقاولون ومهندسون الاوضاع في تركيا اختلط
فيها الانساني بالسياسي خاصه مع اقتراب
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه في مايو
المقبل المعارضه قالت ان حمله الاعتقالات
التي طالت المقاولين تغافلت عمن اسمتهم
بالمسؤولين الاساسيين عن الكارثه وهم
المطورون المتنفذون والمرتبطون بكبار
المسؤولين منتقده في الوقت نفسه الاستجابه
الحكوميه البطيئه كما وصفتها بعد حدوث
الزلزال زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري المعارض
كمال كليتش دار اوغلو قال ان الحكومه حولت
المنازل الى من خلال العفو عن المباني
المشيده خلافا للمواصفات الزلزال وقانون
العفو لعام 2018 قضيه سياسيه رئيسيه في
تركيا قبل ثلاثه اشهر فقط من الانتخابات
العامه لكن ما هو هذا القانون قانون العفو
هذا البرنامج اقر قبل خمسه اعوام وقنن
اوضاع ملايين المباني منها الكثير التي
خالفت معايير الابنيه المقاومه للزلزل او
الزلازل بطبيعه الحال صحيفه قالت ان
الحكومه التركيه تواجه رد فعل عنيف متزايد
خاصه وان القانون اسفر عن اخطاء في ملايين
المباني في جميع انحاء تركيا وبشكل او
باخر ادى لانتشار ممارسات البناء السيئه
التي كشفها زلزال الاسبوع الماضي اشارت
الصحيفه الى ان السلطات التركيه وافقت على
سبعه ملايين و400 الف طلب لتقنين اوضاع
المباني خلال اول عام ونصف من صدور هذا
القانون مع اخضاع المطورين والمقاولين
لرسوم مقابل ان يشملهم القانون وحينها
جمعت السلطات نحو اربعه مليارات و200
مليون دولار كرسوم تسجيل المباني وفقا
لوزاره البيئه التركيه
واسرد جورنال التقت بمختصين في التخطيط
الحضري وقالوا ان النطاق الواسع للقانون
ينطبق على كل شيء تقريبا بني بشكل مخالف
للمطلوب وانه اعطى اشاره للمقاولين بان
المباني غير القانونيه سيتم تقنينها في
نهايه المطاف بغض النظر عن مواصفات البناء
وكانت التقديرات الرسميه الاخيره اشارت
الى ان حوالي نصف المباني في تركيا او 13
مليون مبنى لا تمتثل للمعايير وفقا لوزاره
البيئه التركيه
[موسيقى]
كلنا نتذكر اللحظات المصوره لماسات
الزلزال وانهيار المباني لكننا سنتوقف عن
انهيار او عند انهيار مبنى معين في ملاطيا
نيويورك تايمز درست عبر مهندسين لحظه سقوط
مبنى قال مطوروه انه مبني ليكون امنا من
الزلازل الا انه لم يصمت شركه المقاولات
قالت ان تشييد المبنى تم وفقا لاحدث
اللوائح وباستخدام اعلى جوده من الخرسانه
المسلحه بقدمان حديديه الا انها اعترفت
باحتمال حدوث خطا هندسي تسبب في انهيار
الطابق السفلي والمبنى بعد ذلك برج شيد
قبل ثلاث سنوات فقط كما نشاهد في هذه
الصور انهارا في الساعات الاولى من
الزلزال وسط سحابه من الغبار بفعل هزه
ارتداديه الصحيفه استعانت بثلاثه مهندسين
قالوا انه من المرجح ان سوء التصميم
الانشائي ادى لسقوط المبنى الذي لم تتحمل
اساساته اثر الزلزال واعتبرت نيويورك
تايمز ان مثل هذه الاخفاقات محيره في دوله
تحظى بخبره تقنيه وهندسيه خاصه وان
المنطقه معروفه بالزلازل الا ان القوانين
المحليه بحسب الصحيفه مصدر قلق اخر مع
تراخي بروتوكولات التفتيش بموجب لوائح
البناء لعام 2007 والذي لا يتطلب فحص
الهياكل بمجرد منح الترخيص للمبنى مما
يعني انه يمكن للمطورين اجراء تعديلات غير
مصرحي بها بدورها نشرت واشنطن بوست تقريرا
قارنت فيه بين التطور في المباني في مناطق
الزلازل وقله عدد الوفيات وضربت مثالا
باليابان وتشيلي وتركيا تشيلي التي شهدت
مقتل 28
الف شخص خلال زلزال عام
1939 طورت من قوانينها ومبانيها لمقاومه
الزلازل حتى وصلت حصيله اخر زلزال في هذه
الدوله عام 2019 الى اربعه قتله فقط خلال
الزلازل التي اقتربت شده او هذا الزلزال
من سبع درجات على مقياس رختر حصيله مماثله
اي اربعه قتلى كانت في زلزال اليابان
العام الماضي بعدما شهدت في الربع الاول
من القرن الماضي زلزالا مدمرا اودى بحياه
اكثر من 140 الف شخص
ننتقل الى تركيا وبعد زلزال ازمير عام
1999 قررت الحكومه التركيه ان المباني
الجديده يجب ان تكون مقاومه للسلاسل لكن
هذا لم يتم تطبيقه بشكل فعلي على الارض
كما تحدثنا منذ قليل عن قانون العفو عن
الابنيه المخالفه لنشهد الكارثه التي
تجاوزت حصيلتها 32 الف شخص حسب التقديرات
الاوليه
وينضم الينا من القاهره الدكتور عباس
الشراقي استاذ الجيولوجيا في جامعه
القاهره اهلا بك معنا دكتور عباس يعني
راينا بالفيديو منذ قليل مبنى مصنف على
انه مقاوم للزلازل او يحتمل الزلازل
شاهدنا كيف انهارت الطوابق السفلى ولكن
بقي المبنى كما هو عندما سقط الطوابق
العليا كيف تفسر ذلك هل نتحدث انه هنا
المشكله بالانشاءات ام بالتخطيط الهندسي
مساء الخير على حضرتك وكل الساده
المشاهدين والحقيقه مشاهدناه في تركيا
يعني شاهدنا انهيار كثير من المباني ونجد
هناك مبنى في المنتصف ثابت هذا يدل على ان
هذا المبنى مبني على الاسس الهندسيه
السليمه وعلى كود الزلازل في حين ان
المباني المجاوره كلها انهارت لان لماذا
لم ينهار هذا المبنى هو الاخر ايضا المبنى
انهار يعني نهار فيه الدور الاول يعني
يتضح ان هناك مشاكل في اعمده في اعمده
الدور الاول
فالاهمال وعدم تطبيق الكود الهندسي وراء
هذه المشاكل اعتقد ان الكود الهندسي موجود
ولكن التطبيق هو
دكتور عباس يعني انت تتحدث ان هناك مشاكل
في الاعمده ولم يتم تطبيق الكود الهندسي
كيف يمكن ان نبسط الامور للناس يعني لن
المشاكل الهندسيه غالبا في كميات الاسياخ
الحديد الموجوده داخل الاعمده الاربطه
سواء من اسفل العمود او من اعلى العمود
لان فيهم المناطق اللي هي فيها زلازل
ومعرضه للزلازل بشده مثل تركيا وطبعا في
منها اشد منها اليابان بيتم
في هناك مواصفات خاصه للاعمده الخرسانيه
وللكمر الخرساني والكل ذلك وبالتالي احنا
بنقول هناك كود هندسي للمناطق المعرضه
للزلازل لابد من تطبيق هذا الكود للاسف في
تركيا او في معظم الدول العربيه لا يتم
تطبيق وكل دوله لها كود خاص بها لان الكود
يعتمد على درجه
او شده الزلازل الموجوده في كل منطقه
فتركيا من المناطق الشديده التعرض للزلازل
يليها سوريا ثم الاردن ثم بعد كده بقيه
الدول العربيه
يعني لابد من التطبيق والمعايير الهندسيه
يتم التاكد من سلامه المباني ومن الكميات
الحديد ومن نوع الاسمنت وغيره من هذه
المواصفات طيب دعنا دكتور عباس مشاهد هذه
الصور لانهيار مبنى ونعلم ما يعني اسبابه
[موسيقى]
جديد اهلا بك دكتور عباس يعني شاهدنا صورا
لمجمع او عده مجمعات بغازي عنتاب التركيه
مباني متشابهه
سقطت
ومبان اخرى ايضا متشابهه لم تنهدم بمعنى
انه المصدر واحد او الجهه التي بنت هي
واحده لماذا
مباني او مجمعات تنهدم بعينها واخرى لا
اذا هي بنفس المنطقه الم يطبق نفس الكود
الهندسي على كل تلك المباني
هو يعني اولا هنا ممكن يكون التنفيذ مختلف
يعني في بتبقى في شركات مقاولين من الباطن
التنفيذ لو اختلف التنفيذ ممكن يكون فيه
يعني نوع من الفساد او غيره يؤدي الى يعني
يعني عدم جوده المبنى ايضا هناك شيء مهم
للغايه ايضا لازم نذكره ربما في بعض
المباني تكون منفذه الكود الهندسي ولكن
هنا في في شيء مهم قوي ان الزلزال انشا
مجموعه من التشققات والفوالق المناطق التي
بها تشقق ويكون عليه مباني اي حتى لو كانت
مطبقه الكود الهندسي فهي هذه المباني لابد
وان تسقط لان هناك فوالق احنا شفنا
الطرق وشفنا السكه الحديد ان هنا هناك
يعني فوالق وحصل ازاحه قدرها حوالي 3 متر
اي مباني تقع في هذه المنطقه تبقى معرضه
يبقى يعني لانهيار حتى ولو كانت مطبقا
لكود لان هنا حصل حركه في القشره الارضيه
من تحتها لكن المباني التي تبعد عن
الفواصل او الفوالق التي ظهرت دي المفروض
انها يعني تقاوم الى حد كبير وليس بهذا
الكم من الاف المباني اللي سقطت بهذا
الشكل الدروس المستفاده الدكتور عباس من
هذا
الزلزال الذي حدث في تركيا
ودفعت ثمنه ايضا سوريا
التطبيق التام لكود الزلازل
ومتابعه المباني اثناء البناء يعني هنا
اللي بيبني مبنى بياخذ ترخيص بعدد الادوار
ثم هنا يجب ان يكون هناك رقابه على تنفيذ
اثناء عمليه البناء بمعنى ان يكون هناك
مهندسين يتم متابعه كميات الحديد
والخرسانه ونوع الاسمنت وغيره طول ما
المبنى بيعلى لازم يكون تحت اشراف
المسؤولين في الدوله شكرا جزيلا لك من
القاهره الدكتور عباس الشراقي استاذ
الجيولوجيا في جامعه القاهره
وتتابعون ولكن بعد الفاصل
مؤسسوا فاجنر الروسيه يلخص الوضع في معركه
بخموت مطحنه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اكد يفغيني
رئيس مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه
لن تسقط قريبا واصفا ما يجري على ارضها
بمطحنه اللحم من جهتي حاكم الموالي لروسيا
قال لم تبدي اي اشاره على التنازل عن
المدينه التي وصفها الرئيس الاوكراني
بانها حصن البلاد
عشره ايام تفصلنا عن الذكرى السنويه
الاولى للحرب في اوكرانيا والتي لا يبدو
ان نهايتها تلوح في الافق الناتو يواصل
الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا الا ان ذخيرته قد
تنفذ خلال ايام ان خضع حربا بحسب تقرير
لينوزويك نيوزويك نقلت عن مسؤولين غربيين
قولهم ان الناتو سيطلب من الاعضاء تعويض
الامدادات المنخفضه عبر زياده الانتاج
النقص بحسب مصادر نيوزريك يكمن في المقام
الاول في القذائف المستخدمه في مدافع
الهاودر وصواريخ هاي مارس وذخائر انظمه
الدفاع مثل الامريكيه بريطانيا مثلا بدات
بالفعل في اتخاذ خطوات للتعويض عن الاسلحه
في ديسمبر اعلن وزير الدفاع ان وزرته
وافقت على خطه لانتاج المزيد من الذخيره
المضاده للدبابات في الولايات المتحده
كشفت وزاره الدفاع عن وجود خطط لتجديد
امداداتها وزيادات مخزون الاسلحه اليوم
ايضا اكد وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن
ان بلاده ستواصل دعم اوكرانيا عسكريا
[موسيقى]
سنبحث في مبادرات صناعيه تضمن استمراريه
دعمنا لاوكرانيا على المدى البعيد ايضا
سنبحث في مسؤوليات المتعلقه بالدعم الامني
الذي نقدمه لاوكرانيا والذي بلغ مستويات
تاريخيه اوكرانيا ملتزمه بان الدعم
العسكري الذي تتلقاه سيصل الى الجنود
الاوكرانيين على الجبهات هذا الاجتماع
ياتي في وقت حرج الكرملين ما زال يراهن ان
بمقدوره ان يفرقنا لكن بعد عام من الحرب
مازلنا متحدين كما كنا سابقا
الامين العام للناتو
يلسدد على ان الحلفه وشركائه سيواصلون دعم
اوكرانيا كي تضمن الانتصار في الحرب
[موسيقى]
التجربه الاوكرانيه دعت الجيش الفرنسي
لاستخلاصي الدروس واجراء تغييرات وذلك
بالاعتماد بشكل اقل على التشكيلات
التقليديه والتوجه نحو الحرب الالكترونيه
او ما يطلق عليها حروب المستقبل رئيس
اركان الجيش الفرنسي اعلن عن تاسيس تنظيم
جديد يتم فيه تقليص افواج المشاه
والدبابات لصالح المتخصصين في الفضاء
الالكتروني والطائرات المسيره واوضح ان
الخطه تندرج ضمن العمل على القانون
المستقبلي الذي سيعرض على مجلس الوزراء في
الربيع بانفاق يتجاوز 400 مليار يورو حتى
عام 2030 صحيفه لموند قالت ان هذه الخطه
تمثل تخليا عن ثقافه التدخل السريع التي
انتهت بانتهاء عمليه برخان في الساحل
الافريقي وان الجيش الفرنسي سيصبح متوسط
العدد بحلول عام 2030
وينضم الينا من باريس الدكتور محمد سيف
الدين الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه والمختص
في الشان الروسي اهلا بك دكتور محمد يعني
اذا الناتو يتخوف من نفاذ الذخيره لديه في
حال نشوب نزاع عسكري مع روسيا كيف لحلف
عسكري مثل الناتو حلف قائم على التبادل
العسكري بين دوله ان يتخوف من هكذا نقطه
من النقص
بذخيرته هل ذلك يعني منطقي
نعم يعني بالتصور الاول لا يبدو ذلك
منطقيا خصوصا اذا نظرنا الى حجم
الاهداف التي يضعها يضعها لنفسه وحجم
المهمات التي يعني توسعت بعد عام 1990
وانهيار حلف وارسلي لتشمل مهمات مكافحه
الارهاب وغير ذلك لكن الحديث عن نفاد
ذخيره النيتو والمخاطر من هذا النفاذ ليس
جديدا في يعني في عام 2011 حينما كان
الناتو يشن الهجوم لفرض حظر جوي في ليبيا
ايضا تم التصريحات بنفس السياق ونشرت
حينها واشنطن بوست يعني ماده عن موضوع
نفاذ ذخيره النيتو واكدتها الاداره
الامريكيه في ذلك الوقت وطلبت من الحلفاء
الاوروبيين تحديدا فرنسا وبريطانيا في ذلك
الوقت التغطيه بهذا الامر وزياده الامداد
بالزخاائر في افغانستان الامر نفسه حصل
بالنسبه بالنسبه للنيتو ايضا كان هناك
تدافع من دول الناتو ارسال عدد اقل من
الجنود وعدد اقل من المعدات دائما في كل
معركه كان النيتو يشهد الظروف نفسها الان
في المواجهه في في اوكرانيا يعني منذ بدات
هذه المواجهه تتكرر هذه المطالبات وتتكرر
هذه التحذيرات من ان الناتو يعني يفقد
الذخيره بشكل سريع جدا يتحدث عن يعني عن
حرق الذخائر في اوكرانيا الاشهر الثلاثه
الماضيه بالطبع شهدت الكثير من استهلاك
الذخيره خصوصا عندما تقدم الجيش الاوكراني
في في محورين من المحاور التي يتم عليها
القتال واذا هناك نقص فعلي للذخيل ايضا
التصريحات التي خرجت
ولكن الدكتور محمد يعني هذه الفجوه التي
يشكو منها حلف الناتو كيف ومتى متى يمكن
ان تسد في ظل استمرار هذه الحرب وبالتالي
استمرار الدول الغربيه بدعم اوكرانيا
نعم يعني بالبدايه يجب النظر الى قوه
الناتو مما تتشكل هذه القوه هنا قوه نوويه
مركزيه في اوروبا هي فرنسا وهي قوه وحيده
نوويه وهناك الاعتماد الامني بشكل يعني
كبير جدا على توفير الحمايه من الولايات
المتحده للفضاء الاطلسي الناتو كحلف عسكري
قام على هذه الحمايه التي توفرها الولايات
المتحده للفضاء العابر للاطلسي وعلى اساس
هذه الحمايه التزمت الدول يعني في الضفه
الاخرى الدول الاوروبيه بهذه الشراكه
وقدمت الكثير من اجل هذه الشراكه الان
توضع هذه الدول امام خيارين اما تتخلى عن
مصادر الطاقه مع اوروبا الشرقيه وتحديدا
مع روسيا واما تتخلى عن هذه الحمايه حتى
الان اختارت هذه الدول ان تتخلى عن
التبعيه للغاز الروسي وان تلتزم بالحمايه
الامنيه من قبل الولايات المتحده وهذا
يفسر بشكل كبير جدا مصادر قوه هذا الحلف
لكن عملي عملي وعلى الارض كلما احتك
الناتو بعدوه من يدفع الثمن هم الحلفاء
الاوروبيين بشكل بشكل رئيس وهذا الامر ما
يشكل خطرا كبيرا في اوكرانيا الان اذا مات
وصل الناتو الى صدام مباشر مع روسيا لن
تحارب الولايات المتحده بشكل مباشر في هذا
الامر شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
التوضيحات الدكتور محمد سيف الدين الباحث
في العلاقات الدوليه والمختص في الشان
الروسي
وتتابعون معنا بعد الفاصل في تركيا وسوريا
كل الم بعد الزلزال قد يمر الا ذلك
الموجود بالاكياس
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنتون انتشار لحطام
كبير من الموقع الذي سقط فيه المنطاد
الصيني بما في ذلك اجهزه الاستشعار وتامل
واشنطن ان يساعدها هذا الكشف في اثبات
قيام الصين بانشطه تجسسيه وحل لغز الاجسام
الطائره ثلاث التي اسقطتها مؤخرا بعد
تعديل عمل راداراتها حتى وان كان البيت
الابيض اكد الرابط الى الان بين هذه
الاجسام
[موسيقى]
الى تصريح اليوم لم اشهد في حياتي مستعمله
دمار كالذي في سوريا التصريحها لمدير
منظمه الصحه العالميه تدرس ادهم بعد ان
ساقه القدر في رحله بين دمشق وحلب يقول
المسؤول ان المنازل على هذه الطريق مجرد
اطلال تخلو من الساكنين وان خسائر اكثر من
عقد من الحرب لا يمكن تصورها ربما لا يمكن
تصورها لكنها صورت ووثقت وموادها تملا
ارشيف كل الهيئات الامميه ومن بينها
ومنظمات الصحه العالميه
فيديو اليوم ايضا من سوريا ضمن احد مراكز
اليونيسف يعمل المتخصصون على علاج الاطفال
نفسيا مما عانوا جراء الزلزال فهناك من
فقدوا الاهل وهناك من نجى باصابه واغلبهم
لا يستطيعون حتى الان استيعاب ما حدث في
سوريا اصبح لدى الاطفال هاجس فان هو الارض
التي قد تهتز من تحتهم بعد ان لازمهم
لسنوات هاجس اول هو السماء وما قد يسقط
منها
صوره اليوم من كهرمان مرعش التركيه اسبوع
كامل من الانتظار ينتهي لكن لم ينتهي كما
تمنت فمن كانت تنتظرهم لم يخرجوا على محفه
انما في اكياس مضى الم او الم وقلق
الانتظار الان وسيمر بعده الم التحديق في
الاكياس واستعاده الذكريات وحين تاتي
عربات نقل الموتى سينتهي الالمان ليبدا
الم ثالث اطول الم الوحده
انتهت ملفاتنا لليوم لديناها
تتتابع وبنفس اطار هذا الزلزال المدمر مع
الزميل صهيب شراير تفضلي يا صهيب مساء
الخير راويه فعلا رغم كل هذه الماسي يجب
ان نتشبث بالامل والدليل بعد تسعه ايام من
الزلزال تسعه اشخاص اخرجوا احياء من تحمل
اليوم الامل دائما موجود شكرا تفضل شكرا
[موسيقى]